if PNN are integers such that p is
greater than and is greater than zero so
this tells us since P is strictly
greater than n that means that there are
two different integers P is the larger
of these two different integers and that
they're both positive they're both are
greater than zero and they tell us that
P squared minus N squared is equal to 12
P squared minus N squared is equal to 12
which of the following can be the value
of P minus the value of P minus n so one
thing that might jump immediately out at
you is that you could factor P squared
minus N squared that this is a
difference of squares and why why it
especially jumps out it use when you
factor it one of the factors is P minus
n so this could be factored as this
could be factored as P plus n times P
minus n this is just factoring a
difference of squares is equal to 12 is
equal to 12 now what we essentially have
is the product of two expressions is
equal to 12 the each of expressions this
expression right over here P plus n this
is the sum of two positive integers this
is a difference of two positive integers
so both of these are going to be
positive both of these are positive
integers the reason why we know P minus
n is a positive integers they tell us
that P is greater than n so this is
going to be a positive value so let's
think about all the different
combinations of positive integers that
we could take their product and get to
12 so it could be and this of course
this is of course is going to be the
larger of the two this is going to be
the larger of the two and this is going
to be the smaller smaller of the two so
let's see you could have 12 times 1 12
times 1 is definitely equal to 12
you could have let's see you could have
6 times 2 which is equal to 12 you could
have 4 times 3 which is also equal to 12
so these are essentially all of the
contenders for P plus N and P minus n so
let's think about how how we can how we
can rule some of these some of these
scenarios
some of these scenarios out so let's
take the first scenario let's say that P
plus n P I'll be writing it in green so
the first scenario let's say that P plus
n is equal to 12 and P minus n is equal
to 1 P minus n is equal to 1 well we
could solve for P here we could add the
left hand sides the left hand sides the
ends cancel out you're left with 2p and
you add the right hand side you get 13 P
you divide both sides by 2 you get P is
equal to 13 over 2 now this is not cool
because this said this contradicts one
of our first assumptions that PE needs
to be an integer this right over here is
not an integer so P plus n cannot be 12
and P minus n cannot be 1 so P minus n
cannot be 1 so actually we can rule this
out right over here P minus n cannot be
1 now let's think about this scenario
where P plus n is equal to 6 P plus n is
equal to 6 that's the larger of the two
factors and P minus N and P minus n is
equal to 2 well same idea we can add the
left hand side we're going to put 2 P
and then the right hand side we get 6
plus 2 is equal to 8 divide both sides
by 2 you get P is equal to 4 and if P is
equal to 4 then you see well is he 4
plus what is equal to 6 well 4 plus 2 is
equal to 6 n is equal to 2 and that
works out here 4 minus 2 is equal to 2
so this is completely consistent both of
these are positive integers they're
different positive integers P is greater
than n so it's completely possible that
P minus n is equal to 2 so this is
completely a possible value of P minus n
and then let's look at this let's look
at this last so this one works out let's
look at this last scenario so we have P
plus n is equal to 4 and P minus n P
minus n is equal to 3 well same idea
the
side you get two P is equal to seven
well once again when you divide both
sides by two P is equal to seven halves
this is not an integer just like here
this cannot be the case because P needs
to be an integer in this case P is being
forced if if P plus n was four and P
minus n is three then you are not going
to have then P is not going to be an
integer so this is also this is also not
a possibility now we could have ruled
this out even without doing that
exercise because if P minus n was four
if P minus n was four then P plus n
would have to be three but P plus n is
going to be the larger of the two values
so P minus n with even if even if this
were even if this were a possible
scenario even if we didn't end up with a
non integer right over here we could
have gotten P minus n 2 3 but not 2 4 P
minus n is going to be the less the
lesser of the two factors between 4 & 3
were even contenders but we know here
that they aren't but anyway we can rule
that one we can rule that one out as
well so the only possible value of P
minus n or the which of the following
can be a value of P minus n 2